[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALI AFSHAR: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google Developers
Live with Google Drive.
I'm Ali.
CARRIE ROWE: I'm Carrie.
ALI AFSHAR: And thanks
for joining us today.
Today, we're going to have a
special look at how you can
get a job in Google Developer
Relations.
That's quite exciting for us.
We're always looking for
talented, passionate engineers.
This is particularly relevant
with a new film that's coming
out about Google.
And of course, we recommend you
go and watch that film.
CARRIE ROWE: Yeah, that's
really exciting.
But first, we've got product
news and announcements.
ALI AFSHAR: So one thing to
announce today, a couple of
weeks ago, we announced that
we're unifying storage across
our Google products.
So before, when users had 5
gigabytes of storage for
Google Drive, now this
is combined.
And you get a 15 gigabyte
free storage.
We think that's really
nice because it
provides choice to users.
If you want to use
it in Gmail, you
can use it in Gmail.
As part of this, the Google
Drive SDK returns the value
for complete storage.
Some apps could check this if
you want to see, does the user
have storage for me to store
a file in there or not?
And now, it returns the
complete value.
So that's our updates
for the week.
CARRIE ROWE: Oh, Ali, did
you build that yourself?
ALI AFSHAR: I didn't build it.
I did write the blog post.
Please check out the blog
post if you would like
more details on that.
But as I say, I think users will
find that useful to have
the choice.
CARRIE ROWE: That's
really exciting.
So now, we know all of you are
really excited to learn about
how you can get a job at Google,
and specifically join
our developer relations team.
And Ali here has interviewed
a ton of people.
And so he is a great expert on
what to do, what not to do.
So Ali, when you've see people
not succeed in our interviews,
are there a few things
that you see
happening all the time?
ALI AFSHAR: There are a few
problems that people do have
that come up again and again.
And if I could just mention
them, they're usually one of
three things.
Firstly, not having adequate
computer science knowledge.
Of course, engineering jobs at
Google, you need a good amount
of computer science knowledge.
The second thing, particularly
useful for developer
relations, is ability to
communicate technical concepts.
Now, we regard that as
a very high skill.
And if you're good at that,
then really it's
something for you.
The third thing is a bit of a
silly one, and it does apply
to wherever you're applying for
a job, resumes that are
incomplete or have information
that just is infactual really
is not a good idea.
So if you say you can do
something on your resume,
really please be able
to do that.
CARRIE ROWE: And that's
really good advice for
wherever you go.
Don't lie on your resume.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
CARRIE ROWE: And so given the
fact that there's a movie
coming out, we thought it'd be
really fun to do our own
little movie.
So let's cue to What Not
to Do in an Interview.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TYPING]
-We're going to start off
with a coding question.
I'd like to see you show me how
to reverse the characters
in a string.
-You do know I'm an engineer
and, you know, I've been
coding for, like, the last
50 years, you know.
-So it shouldn't be difficult.
-Come on, I'm not here to
play your stupid games.
-So I see on your resume that
you've used Django for three.
Years can tell me the advantages
of Django over
other Python frameworks?
-Is that on my resume?!
-So why Google?
-I mean, Google, Microsoft,
Facebook--?
-Why developer relations?
-So I tried to apply as a SWE,
as a software engineer.
But I got rejected.
So I thought I might try
developer relations.
-You just finished
your PhD program.
Can you tell me about your
research that you've been
doing for the past
seven years?
-Uh, I, um, mm--.
-What are you interested in
when you're not at work?
What do you like to do
with your free time?
-I write code.
-So now that we have a few
minutes left, it's your chance
to ask me any questions
you might have
about Google of Devrel.
-Um, no thanks.
I know everything.
-Oh.
[END VIDEO PLYBACK]
CARRIE ROWE: Wow, Ali.
You are a really bad actor.
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks, Carrie.
CARRIE ROWE: Don't quit your
day job as an engineer.
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks, Carrie.
Obviously, that wasn't one
of my proudest moments.
But it should give you an idea
of some of the common mistakes
you can make.
To make up for that, we have
made a video of slightly
better answers for these.
And hopefully, here is where
I can regain some of my
credibility.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TYPING]
-We're going to start off
with a coding question.
I'd like to see you show me how
to reverse the characters
in a string.
-Really interesting question.
I've often thought about that.
Do you mind if I write some
code on the board?
-No, that's perfect.
Please go ahead.
-Excellent, thank you.
-OK, great.
Thanks for showing
me this code.
Now, I'd like you to take
a moment to explain the
algorithmic complexity
of your solution.
-Sure, it's clearly O(n).
We're running through each
character in the string once.
Obviously, it does depend
on the complexity of
your hashing algorithm.
But apart from that, I'm
confidently saying O(n) here.
-So now can you please tell
me how the internet works?
-Sure!
The internet is a series of
connected computers all around
the world which know how to
communicate with each other,
and they're used for the
exchange of data and
information.
Anyone can connect to
the internet with
many different clients.
And you connect your client to
the internet, and you can use
that to fetch data, send data.
And that's how we
browse the web.
That's how we make calls
on video conferencing.
That's basically how
the web works.
Any specific details about it
you'd like to know more?
-No, I just wanted to see
how you'd explain it.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
-So I see on your resume that
you've used Django for the
last three years.
Can you tell me some of the
advantages of Django over
other Python frameworks?
-You say advantages.
If I could possibly put some
advantages and some
disadvantages of Django?
Because obviously, when you
get to know this framework
well, you'll see that there
are good and bad points.
The advantages are--
-So why developer relations?
Why DevRel?
-I've worked for the last few
years on developer products.
And I'm really passionate
about the developer
experience.
I think if developers write good
products, especially on
Google platforms, that's a good
thing for developers, and
good thing for Google,
and ultimately a
good thing for users.
-So why Google?
-Google has the opportunity to
work on the biggest, most
impactful projects that are
affecting our world today, the
chance to touch the lives of
everyone in the world.
And there aren't many other
places I can do that.
-When you aren't at work,
what do you like to do?
What are you interested in?
-I play sports, you know.
I run.
I play soccer.
We call it football,
of course.
And I spend time
with my family.
-So now that we have a few
minutes left, you have a
chance to ask me
some questions.
-Sure.
Could you tell me, for example,
what a typical day at
work involves for you?
-I'd be happy to.
-Thanks.
I'm so [INAUDIBLE]
Google.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARRIE ROWE: Ali, you were much
better in that video.
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks, Carrie.
CARRIE ROWE: And actually, hey,
you are good enough to
work at Google.
How about that?
ALI AFSHAR: Who knew?
Thanks.
That's really great.
CARRIE ROWE: So if you do
really well in all your
interviews, you can
get hired on the
developer relations team.
And you get one of
these cool hats.
And the tail spins.
So please check out our website,
jobs.google.com, to
learn more about all of the
positions that we have open.
And we would love for you to
apply to developer relations.
And so if you go to the
jobs.google.com website, if
you specifically search for
developer advocate or
developer programs engineer,
you'll be able to learn more
about the specific roles on
our team and the types of
skills and responsibilities
that we're looking for.
ALI AFSHAR: And we're really
excited to hear from you.
I'm available, too, if you have
any questions on what our
typical day of work involves,
or the kind of problems we
come up against, and
the kind of things
we're trying to solve.
I'm always available to chat.
So that's great.
So now, we'll go to our regular
segment, which Carrie
is going review an application
for us.
MALE SPEAKER: App of the Week.
CARRIE ROWE: All right, so
today, we're going to talk
about Lucid Charts.
And they're one of our
first drive apps.
So we're really excited
to demo them today.
So for anybody's who's ever
created PowerPoint
presentations, one of the most
painstaking parts is creating
all of these flow diagrams,
org charts.
And now, Lucid Charts allows you
to create that directly in
Google Drive, which
is fantastic.
You can create it once,
share it with
everybody, edit it together.
Let's take a look.
So I've installed Lucid Chart
Diagrams through the connect
more apps through the Drive
Chrome Web Store.
And let's take a look at how
easy it is to create an app.
So while it's loading, I think
I want to create a chart on
Harry Potter.
Because I love Harry Potter.
So let's call this
Harry Potter.
So one of the things we talked
about in how to get a job at
Google, you have to be a super
interesting, geeky person.
I kind of geek out about
Harry Potter.
So let's see how you do this.
So I want to create a chart
for Harry Potter.
So it's as easy as dragging
and dropping a flow chart
diagram over here.
So let's call it Harry Potter.
He's the most important one.
And then, beneath him, let's
add in his friends.
Hermione, Ron, and we
can't forget Hedwig.
And then, what's really cool,
too, they have all this super
easy functionality.
If you want to connect stuff,
there are arrows.
It's as easy as click
and drag.
And then, if I go back
to my Drive, it's
right here in my drive.
And that's so--
it's a wonderful integration.
We love to see all
the cool things
developers do with our products.
It's really great.
ALI AFSHAR: So yeah,
I love Lucid Chart.
As Carrie said, one of our
oldest apps, and one I use
just about every day, really
fantastic and great
integration.
So please, try them out.
That's really great.
So thank you, everyone,
for joining us.
That's us for this week.
Hopefully, you'll join
us again next week.
And if you have any questions,
please catch up with us in the
Google Drive community.
We're waiting to
hear from you.
Thanks very much.
CARRIE ROWE: Thanks, everybody!
Bye!
[MUSIC PLAYING]